what do you get this extreme headaches
when you work out or when you lift
weights my head video editor he says
that after his workout sometimes he
needs to sit inside his car and wait for
30 minutes just for the headache to go
away because otherwise he can't drive
home safely so why does this happen
well in most cases this is called an
exertional headache and this happens
when you exert yourself and the muscles
on your head neck and scalp need a lot
more blood circulation
so your blood volume basically increases
in your blood vessels which can cause a
very painful headache now I need to know
there's a few things that can make this
headache worse the first thing is not
drinking enough water so dehydration
then your DNA meaning a history in
migraines and if it's very hot on the
day you're working out
not too much time in the sun can also
give you an extreme headache so let's
say you go down to the beach for the day
you spend a lot of time there you get
burned and then you want to go and work
out it's not a good idea because you
will get a headache another cause for
headaches might be because you have low
blood sugar and if this is you you might
also start shaking you might feel dizzy
sweat a lot more or feel extremely
hungry have blurry vision disorientation
or even struggle to concentrate now this
can also happen especially when you do
intermittent fasting let me explain
so you wake up you go through the day
you don't eat anything so you go through
the day you work out you burn through
glucose
so that gives you low blood sugar also
known as hypoglycemia
another factor is stress some guys when
they work out they're just in their
thoughts and thinking about everything
you think about your goals obstacles and
also your problems if you focus on
things that give you stress all the time
you know it's good I also think a lot
when I work out sometimes we are so busy
through the day we're just busy busy
busy and then when you work out you're
in your thoughts and you're thinking
about all these things but without
realizing it you might have created a
habit where you start to focus a lot
more on the problems in your life and
then you feel stressed and you don't
even realize it that's not good not for
you or your body and the warning sign
that your body will give you is a
headache your body has been created to
be well amazing to heal yourself to
repair and build back muscles bigger and
so many other cool things and you might
forget that your body is connected to
your soul
and if it's not going good with you
psychologically
it will impact your body this is why so
many people get sick get a cold when
they go on holiday because they don't
realize that they did stages in this Rat
Race work work work work work and they
push themselves they push their bodies
to the brim and the moment they take Lee
from work they relax and their body just
caves in and you get sick
the Bible says in Proverbs 17 22 a
joyful heart is good medicine but a
crushed Spirit dries up the bones
that is so true you know if you are
depressed you don't feel that good it's
going to take you a lot longer to
recover or you might even get worse
doctors know this people who feel good
psychologically if you have joy peace
then you will recover a lot faster if
you are stressed and if you want to find
that kind of peace that surpasses all
understanding even in difficult
situations
and watch this video here and I'll see
you there and before you go always
remember life is short so don't waste
yours cheers guys